salut aujourd'hui on est samedi et
samedi c'est le jour du master class
depuis le début de l'année le samedi le
master class acer apprendre un truc un
peu plus consistant en un peu plus
concret un petit peu plus poussée c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui même si ça va
être un petit peu différent première
différence vous n'aurez pas manqué de
constater qu'il va être 11h30 quand la
vidéo sortira parce que ce matin la
dernière minute je changer mes plans et
j'ai décidé de faire cette vidéo celle
que je suis en train de faire deuxième
différence le rapport entre ce master
class et le mentaliste mais un tout
petit peu différent de d'habitude
puisque le vrai sujet de ce master class
c l'intermittence du spectacle et
comment on arrive à vous manipuler pour
vous faire croire que ce sont des gros
branleur depuis des années on voit les
communications de certains médias ou
alors du medef
hier les intermittents coûte cher les
intermittents sont des privilégiés et
chose qui me fait encore plus mal et qui
m'a motivé à faire cette vidéo ce matin
c'est de voir d'autres artistes défendre
notre cause est en fait se tromper sur
la manière de défendre notre cause
puisque dans les vidéos je vois passer
on oublie de dire l'essentiel avant de
vous expliquer la magnifique et subtile
manipulation à base de détournement
d'attention et de mathématiques parce
que celle ci elle est tellement
magnifique qu'il faut que je vous la
raconte après il faut que je pose une
base simple intermittents du spectacle
n'a jamais été un statut social c'est
une annexe le pôle emploi il ya l'annexé
8 evans etc se disent c'est un moyen
d'indemnisation c'est à dire on n'a pas
une pièce pour nous qui s'occupe des
intermittents non on fait partie de la
solidarité interprofessionnelle c'est à
dire que chaque intermittents qui
travaille paie ses cotisations comme
tout le monde il le met dans la cagnotte
des cotisations interprofessionnelle et
ensuite ceux qui ne travaillent pas
touche une indemnité mais comme
n'importe qui et vous allez me dire
pourquoi on a créé des annexes
spécifiques et bien c'est une bonne
question c'est un peu comme l'annexé iv
qui ont bien morflé d'ailleurs aux
dernières négociations n'en a pas trop
parlé ça ce sont les intérimaires il y a
des années que ce spécial parce que la
manière de travailler est spécial c'est
à dire on travaille en discontinuité on
ne travaille pas chaque jour de la
semaine
on ne travaille pas selon le système
standard aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
travaille dans le système général peu
travaillé durant plusieurs mois
plusieurs années en cdi ou en cdd et un
moment donné est au chômage pendant un
an deux ans en deux ans et demi et c'est
évidemment ça ne peut pas s'appliquer un
rythme de travail discontinue tel que
celui des artistes et des techniciens
donc ils ont créé des annexes pour ça
pour avoir une solution pour nous
indemniser cette solution c'est que nous
avons un quota d'heures à réaliser
durant une période de 10 mois et demi
maximum et si nous réalisons ce cola
dans nous sommes indemnisés pendant 243
joue tout en sachant que si je fais un
spectacle à l'heure j'ai une journée et
demie d'indemnisation qui me sera retiré
je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails l'idée vraiment
à retenir c'est qu'en fait intermittents
du spectacle n'est pas un statut c'est
une catégorie chez pôle emploi
c'est une annexe chez pôle emploi qui a
été créée parce que notre rythme de
travail est spécifique dont il fallait
une manière de nous indemniser
spécifiques et elle est loin de nous
privilégié personne en vie notre place
en réalité je vous assure deuxième point
retenir avant de vous parler de cette
grosse manipulation les intermittents du
spectacle ne sont pas que des gens qui
font du spectacle vivant tous les films
que vous voyez les émissions de radio
que vous aimez écouter les journaux
souvent que vous lisez les spectacles
que vous allez voir tout ce qui a un
rapport avec la culture un rapport avec
le système d'indemnisation des
intermittents du spectacle pour un film
il faut des scénaristes et dialoguistes
etc
d'ailleurs faut savoir que eux n'ont pas
le droit l'intermittence ils ont aucune
assurance chômage
alors qui perd énormément de cotisation
pour jose mais les cadreurs les
tourneurs les monteurs les comédiens
bien souvent les maquilleurs les
coiffeuses alors que ça c'est interdit
d'ailleurs sont intermittents du
spectacle l'intermittent du spectacle
n'est pas que celui qui est sur scène
dans un petit théâtre de 20 places mais
lorsqu'on dit s'il ya plus le régime de
l'intermittence on tue les cultures je
ne suis pas d'accord
ce qu'on tue surtout c'est le droit à
l'indemnisation je rappelle encore une
fois plus nous cotisons nous cotisons
aux caisses de l'assurance chômage
il ya cent dix mille à intermittents en
france via 110 milles intermittents et à
peu près 4 intermittente sur dix qui
sont indemnisés chaque mois 4 sur 10 et
c'est pas spécifique à l'annexé 1 8 l
annexe se disent c'est le cas pour tous
les chômeurs est à peu près quatre
chômeurs sur dix qui sont indemnisés
chaque mois en france
et là attention on va se régaler au
niveau de la manipulation à travers les
chiffres
je vous rappelle ce qu'on vous présente
on vous dit et c'est vrai que les
intermittents du spectacle représente 3
4 % des chômeurs c'est une réalité que
l'indemnisation de ces 110 milles
intermittents ça coûte un milliard
d'euros c'est vrai aussi et enfin on
nous explique que lui ne dit que pôle
emploi est déficitaire de 1,5 milliard
d'euros c'est vrai aussi ça c'est une
réalité donc on vous présente la
conclusion suivante les 110 milles
intermittents qui représente uniquement
3,4 pour cent des chômeurs sont
responsables de 75 % du déficit c'est
magique mais moi je vais vous rajoutez
quelques autres informations la première
c'est que cent mille chômeurs indemnisés
quel qu'il soit que ce soit des bouchers
des mécanos des secrétaires peu importe
cent mille chômeurs indemnisés coûte un
milliard d'euros qu'ils soient
intermittents du spectacle ou pas après
pas oublié de le préciser ça et comparer
ce que coûte une branche professionnelle
par rapport au déficit
n'a aucun sens si je fais la même
démonstration sur cent mille artisans
par exemple je vais obtenir le même
calcul 1 je veux dire voilà cent mille
artisans ça coûte un milliard d'euros
alors que le déficit il est de 1.5
milliards d'euros depuis quand on
compare ça avec un déficit en plus de ça
qu'on calcule le coût d'un milliard
d'euros on calcule juste les dépenses et
le disque en fait on avait cotisé à un
moment donné et on l'avait parodie ça
dans la démonstration
un petit calcul très simple qui devrait
vous plaire aussi qui date de 2011
en 2011 la différence entre les
cotisations perçues et les indemnités
versées d'un point de vue général de
tout pôle emploi de tout l'unedic était
de 4,5 milliards d'euros d'excédent je
parle un 4 5 milliards d'euros de
cotisations en plus que ce qui est sorti
qu'est ce t'as fait tout ce pognon paul
donc il y avait 4 5 milliards d'euros
d'excédent entre les cotisations et ce
qu on ressortait mais le fonctionnement
général de toute l'activité peu l'emploi
unedic était de 6 milliards d'euros 6
milliards d'euros donc en 2011 en a fini
avec un déficit d'1 25 milliard d'euros
sur ce coup là j'ai quand même tendance
à dire que c'est paulo qui est lui-même
responsable de son propre déficit parce
qu'au niveau cotisation ça allait pour
tout le monde là je parle des
intermittents mais je parle de toutes
les branches professionnelles quelle
qu'elle soit je précise parce que ça
aussi on avait apparemment oublié de
d'en parler en gros dans les journaux
sur sa page facebook samuel churin qui
fait énormément énormément énormément
pour bat pour les intermittents mais
aussi pour les précaires d'une manière
générale explique que le coût de
fonctionnement de pôle emploi coûte 10 %
des recettes des cotisations qui
arrivent chaque année soit 3 milliards
d'euros mots ce moment même où je vous
parle c'est parce que c'est beaucoup
quand même 3 milliards d'euros enfin
faut faut revoir des trucs quoi j'étais
un peu moins de stylo je sais pas où on
va envoyer moins de moins de courrier en
fait mais il ya un problème c'est pas
compétitif ça vous savez le grand jeu de
certains syndicats et de certains médias
ces derniers étaient un petit peu le
côté voilà il coûte très très cher les
intermittents c'est pas vrai c'est un
mensonge on vient de le voir c'est une
manipulation réalité ce n'est pas un
système spécifique privilégier une
caisse à part celle du chômage en fait
c'est tout simplement le droit au
chômage après avoir cotisé
ce n'est pas viable et stable dans le
temps c'est à dire sera agréable et
confortable d'être dans ce système là on
est
jean remise en question l'indemnisation
est assez faible et c'est un vrai combat
de tous les jours pour savoir quand est
ce qu'on va renouveler indemnisés je
passe ma vie a expliqué aux copains
comment ça fonctionne parce que c'est
très très compliqué à comprendre et donc
au delà même de la culture on va revient
de tout l'indemnisation chômage
en général je pense que ce sujet
méritait un master class j'espère que ça
vous servira un petit peu à y voir un
peu plus clair dans cette nébuleuse de
c'est quoi ces artistes l'intermittence
etc samedi prochain on reviendra sur du
master class plus classique et je vous
dise je vous parlerai de comment réussir
vos examens est-ce que ça arrive bientôt
demain c'est dimanche donc ce sera plus
cool je vais vous expliquer un tour pour
bluffer vos amis et sinon c'est toujours
une vidéo par jour pendant un an depuis
ce 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain à 11 heures pour le
prochain mentale violent ciao